sur le plan il y a deux sujets il y a le
sujet du plan résiduel de l'incendie et
il y a le sujet de l'utilisation du
plomb pour la restauration de la
cathédrale
s'agissant du premier point là aussi
sous l'effet
salutaire évidemment de Madame Rambaud
inspective du travail dédié à la
cathédrale le respect admirable que nous
faisons moi le premier des conditions
des options à prendre pour le plomb vous
savez que j'ai été chef d'état-major des
armées je suis allé dans les usines de
préparation de nos armements nucléaires
ce qu'on exigeait de nous en tel
secrétaire et n'a rien à voir avec ce
que l'on demande pour pénétrer sur le
chantier de la cathédrale quand le
président de la République vient à la
cathédrale comme le compagnon de base il
perçoit ses bottes et moi tous les jours
ça ça combinaison
ces sous-vêtements ces sous-vêtements
son casque il va nous allons sur la zone
dite sale le terme en soi déjà n'est pas
neutre
nous faisons ce que nous avons à faire
sur la cathédrale nous nous revenons
nous nous dénudons complètement
nous prenons une douche et nous
récupérons nos affaires vous me
permettrez comment
il y a eu des refus là-dessus voilà donc
nous réfléchissons et nous n'avons
strictement aucune incident alors vous
parlez des enfants nous ne voyons pas
d'enfants sur le chantier de la
cathédrale le deuxième sujet que vous
avez soulevé c'est le choix du plomb et
dans votre question vous avez laissé
sous-entendre madame la sénatrice que
cette question avait été cette sujet
avait été pris de manière légère mais
elle a été prise conformément
aux règles de la rénovation des
monuments historiques en France c'est à
dire qu'il y a un organisme qui
s'appelle la CNPA la Commission
nationale du patrimoine et
l'architecture qui émet un avis sur la
base des études qu'elle fait et qui a
donc donné
donner son un avis favorable à la
reconstruction en plomb pour des raisons
que vous avez rapidement évoqué
maléabilité etc etc etc document de
musique etc mais nous sommes là madame
alors j'insiste sur le fait que le plomb
ce sera la couverture du Grand comble et
la flèche
vous avez parlé des enfants je reçois
des lettres absolument extraordinaires
nous ne verrons jamais un enfant allait
se promener sur le grand comble nous ne
verrons jamais un enfant allait lécher
le les plaques de plomb mis sur les
chaînes qui reconstituent la flèche
autrement dit ce risque là est très
exactement égal à 0
le risque résiduel de l'emploi du plomb
sur la couverture du Grand comble et la
flèche est liée aux eaux de
ruissellement
nous allons être des précurseurs
absolument géniaux en matière de
d'analyse des eaux de ruissellement nous
allons mettre en place un dispositif qui
à travers les 104 commerciaux le nombre
de garouilles de violer le LUC déjà
violer le duc Villeneuve pour reprendre
l'expression de monsieur le sénateur
nous allons donc récupérer par les gags
toutes les eaux de pluie dans des
dispositifs que nous allons mettre au
sol et nous allons les analyser pour
voir le plomb qu'elle contienne avant de
les reverser dans la scène nous sommes
véritablement exemplaires ça n'a jamais
été fait donc soyez rassurés aucun
enfant de France n'aura de plomberies en
raison de la reconstruction du plomb en
plomb de notre âme de Paris j'ajoute que
[Musique]
au début quand j'étais nommé dans cette
fonction je disais je suis commandant la
tasse force Notre-Dame etc en réalité je
ne me lasse jamais et j'en viens
d'ailleurs aux nombreuses questions qui
m'ont été posées sur le contrôle de nos
dépenses je ne sais plus quel sénatrice
inspirait nous expliquer qu'on avait
aucune visibilité sur la manière dont
nos coûts étaient etc je vais vous
lister le nombre d'organismes on ne peut
pas bouger un petit doigt sans que 25
personnes viennent contrôler ce que nous
faisons donc j'ai fait cette dégression
pourquoi rappelez-moi
oui alors ce n'est pas moi qui signe les
ce n'est pas moi qui signe des
autorisations de travaux
comme pour tout monument historique
c'est le préfet d'Île-de-France patron
de la drague
vous imaginez pas
l'intérêt le travail précis avec lequel
le préfet a contrôler tout ce qui avait
très à la à la à l'utilisation du plomb
sur la cathédrale le document qu'il a
signé est un véritable chef-d'oeuvre de
droit administratif qui prend en compte
tout ce qu'il est possible de prendre en
compte pour s'entourer de toutes les
mesures de précaution possible et
imaginables madame la sénatrice je ne
vois pas en dehors de renoncer au plomb
bien évidemment pourquoi ça reste à
définir je ne vois pas en quoi
l'utilisation du plomb dans la
reconstruction de notre âme de Paris
puisse pour faire poser le moindre
danger que ce soit sur les enfants
j'ajoute que conformément à la
législation française le
[Musique]
le décret c'est un décret d'autorisation
de travaux a été affichée sur nos murs
pendant deux ans pendant deux mois nous
avons atteint pendant d'avoir attendu
tous les jours de voir si on a les
contester personne n'a contesté
l'utilisation du plomb je crois qu'il
faut aussi c'est bien de discuter etc
mais je crois aussi qu'il faut d'abord
faire preuve d'humilité dans ces
questions à te mettre qu'on n'a pas de
soi seul la vérité sur les choses et une
fois qui est décisions est prise avec
toutes les instances qui caractérisent
notre pays et bien on a on l'accepte et
on puisse aller de l'avant sinon nous
mettrions évidemment 50 ans à
reconstruire la cathédrale Notre-Dame de
Paris